quelle belle journée dans le sud je
retrouve les copains et la nouvelle
maison de karine le marchand et c'est là
on se dit quand même que peut-être les
frais qualifié cela augmente
ses pochettes pas karine
c'est vraiment c'est sympa mais disons
au niveau de l'isolation c'est vachement
bien foutu ce très beau voilà faut
savoir que c'est ça la vie de
l'animatrice préférée des français allez
courage
[Musique]
prouvez tournage d'un film de boeck à
paris
[Musique]
il
via
[Musique]
baisse en trois versions celle où c'est
à plus de 5 de la bct groupe bizarre en
fait besoin de l'institut d'or tout nu
ba 103 7 arrive à dormir sans
couvertures ni free agent besson doit
c'était vers se passe on s'agite est
rouge et meaux b 112,6 atari de faire
des conversations alors tu es tout seul
mais sans toi si tu te donnes des défis
en marchant genre dehors bassin
l'institut aval souvent touch ring comme
un bain savoir si tu fais souvent des
scénarios de ta tête bessat bah si tu
rigoles pour n'importe quoi vincent du
système la réglisse ou six noms mais eh
ben ça doit cesser un jour tu es déjà
tombé dans les escaliers